we did a huge conceptual lesson
yesterday okay so now we're going to get
a little more into the nuts and bolts so
what's your two best I've done these two
things just serve them BA what's going
on for the four and I've actually I can
now finally just say it without any of
we're not any worried that I'm going to
remind you something that I haven't
rested for the four conic sections right
and I've got about three of them for the
four conic sections we're very familiar
with circles and we are very familiar
with parabolas and so the topic
colleagues kind of focuses on these
notes because they had much of you up
now for each of these we have a critical
algebraic relationship which shows for
the ellipse which generally looks
something like this and for the
hyperbola which looks something like
this there is a critical relationship
between the a and the B which are all
about those horizontal and vertical
proportions like how much it's stretched
this way how much it stretched that way
and with the eccentricity of the conic
section okay so the relationship is v
square equals now for an ellipse what's
B squared equal to a square 1 minus miss
very good at four o'clock you morning
for a hyperbola it is reversed for the 1
minus C squared right so it's still B
squared and a squared but if you have to
specify this work please please please
with like a comb or something right
Hotel like this is this a reason why
this is not just a random algebra that I
need to like memorize like
which if what you remember is that an
ellipse has an eccentricity in the range
of 0 to 1 then it must make sense that
is is going to be a small number like
it's a faction you swear it against the
smaller and 2 in order for everything to
stay positive he armed you've got to
have 1 minus a squared whereas if he's
gonna be some big number like 2 or 3 or
500 and then a lot of the things to stay
positive
maybe the beam to step on you this way
then e squared has to be up to front
okay please get that there's meaning
behind this order do not memorize these
videos algebraic statements now once you
use these like let's go back to ellipses
which are a little more familiar with
asperity we're doing fun of them what do
you think going to do once you start
with that level what do i do off that
okay yeah very good
whatever they might be and that'll give
me the eccentricity which I then used to
find the foci under sources these are
the main features right and we saw that
the third higher we can find at this is
the ellipse they're at where are they
plus or minus AE common zebra and of
course this is a we're all thinking just
it's standards at the moment like the
original instances horizontally oriented
right so that's why my fav I thought
that way and the director sees our we're
very good so again they've gone this way
and I've got these vertical lines
happening for the outsides of my owners
yeah Leslie and I did bother going into
the geometry of it because it ends up
being number one prior Pentiums number
two MV genetic proof number three you
end up the exact same Hansa the Third
Kind director sees for the hyper block
ah those corners what the hyperbola
or features their new lives because of
that the geometry of its shape and for
instance we notice that they were
asymptotes and whenever you grab
something with asymptotes it's important
that you should state what the answers
are in you show you then I'm gonna show
them into how you find what the
asymptotes are is what other feature
that's important and they call them
furnaces now for an ellipse you would
say I've got a shape and it intersects
with the corner accident summer one two
three four intercepts for our regular
ellipse that's centered on the origin
obviously that's not centered on the
origin if I if I drew somewhere it might
have no actual intercepts but those are
still the critical points but for our
panel on the intercepts are not just in
two cells they represent a change in the
behavior of a hyperbola right is that
it's the same behavior that we see in a
parabola right ways that it's a turning
point
yeah being that these up and I put it in
better colors these turning points are
oriented horizontally right you can't
really call these turning points the way
we would think about the oculus okay
because there's not a change for life
negative gradient or positive radius
there's not even a gradient in here and
the gradient is two different things
because it's a relationship right so
that's why I call these two many points
even if it's fun
and look like we're gonna call them
faces now on this hyperbola you might
have ribbon you can't find any
y-intercepts you can't find them so you
look for the X intercepts by letting y
equal 0 so look at that what are the
vertices going to be when you solving
this equation plus or minus a right now
it comes your way so I'm going to pause
thank you
that's fairly easy to see now let's get
our baskets let's this they'll give some
algebra back out and let's go after
these asymptotes I'm going to start by
writing the equation on his head but
that's gonna be much time point and I
want to know ok we pulled a bit of a
trick with square roots and limiting
behavior last time you saw I think for
our example there's a square root of 3
times X plus or minus the square root of
3 present those are the two as it takes
we go
so what I want to do now is that same I
want to rehearse that same method but
I'm gonna have to deal with the algebra
so first thing I'm gonna need to get my
square and I'll get you buddies
so it looks to me like if I hang cubes
that side I'll subtract here to that
side so I'm getting x-men
take one okay this is good to remember
what I did after this yeah I'm gonna
multiply to do to get this into the
later but careful it's B squared okay so
Y squared equals this now at this point
I can either oh yeah at this point I'm
at a couple of things I can do come I
didn't awkward a factorizing steps about
the factorization the didn't look
obvious it was very counterintuitive but
a put an x squared in denominated you
remember when i factor right now so a
couple different ways I can do it
basically I factorize that this whole
first term right to get one [ __ ] about
more whether one was so important it's
gonna comment after the square root so
if I bring B squared a squared x squared
all out the front like you get one
takeaway yeah this very much more it's a
B square there so looks like I'm gonna
be left with a squared on x squared + 4
y squared over here what step now before
it gets to my own actually it's possible
minus the square root of all of that
okay however I can do this now that you
know what the answers going to be you
can see all of these things being
squared out the phone I can probably
actually write that right the beginning
and they lead to square root on to Leila
right the square root of this is gonna
be be on any part of this is gonna be X
now just keep in mind by the way the
square root of a square is it absolute
value but why do I don't really worry
about that because of a puzzle - kind of
their rights act and then you've got
this time left under the square root
okay just run out of space unfortunately
but now I can get my limiting behavior
happening right because when I take the
limit as X approaches infinity right you
can see this term vanishes away and you
just get one underneath the square root
so that leaves you with this in the
example we looked at before beyond a was
rude rings okay sir there those then the
asymptotes right so I can actually just
say look I can go straight to this now I
don't need to rehearse this person every
single time I can just go ahead and
agitate Y is going to be equal to plus
or minus B on a X that's how the
proportions gives the ass